hey fellas you doing all that cursing
but even know what those words came from
theologist oh [ __ ]
for example Oh red light well [ __ ] it
[ __ ] is thought to be in relation to the
words to move back and forth and to
strike from Swedish German and Dutch
languages it was used in a coded poem
around 1475 ad and when decoded roughly
translates to they are not in heaven
because they [ __ ] the wives of Ely
historically the first throw shade and
[ __ ] not something you always called
lassie the direct origins of the word
are questionable likely first used as an
insult against women in the 14th and
15th century bad move Billy what's
working came from us with the official
definition being the description of a
donkey
and that's what we call from a see their
classes how could we forget [ __ ]
originally not a bad word at all
gee-whiz Becca you're dribbling sure his
[ __ ] coming from Old English German and
Dutch then we can't forget damn for
example if Stacey said damn Billy when
you gonna let me get a piece of that ass
there you go Stacey damn comes from a
Latin word to condemn or to conflict'
loss on the term is associated with hell
and it was popularized by 18th century
poet Alexander Pope with the phrase
damned with faint praise thanks for
joining us and we'll see you next time
on the origins of God's words